Speaker 1: Let's go next to Scipio in California,
Scipio.
Your next.
Speaker 4: Hey, David, do I sound OK?
You sound great.
OK, cool, so I'm from California, so I've
been following the California recall election,
yes.
So I wanted to ask you a couple of things.
Sure.
How do you think the California recall is
going to go?
Who do you think is going to come out on top?
And if the worst case scenario happens where
Larry Elder gets the win, how do you think
that would go?
Speaker 1: So I am increasingly confident
that when it was 50 50 in terms of keep or
remove Gavin Newsom, not enough people were
really paying attention yet.
And over the last 10 days, as many shows,
including ours, have been talking more and
more about the recall, we've seen Gavin Newsom
pull to almost like a 10 point lead for keeping
him rather than removing him.
So I'm cautiously optimistic that Gavin Newsom
is going to stay now if he doesn't.
And Larry Elder becomes the governor of California,
I think it would be so horrifying that I'm
not even ready to to make any predictions
as to what would happen.
I think it would be untold orders of magnitude
disaster.
And I'm sort of trying not to even take it
that seriously because it would be so horrible.
And I'm optimistic that Gavin Newsom will
stay.
Speaker 4: Yeah, I feel the same way, and
my family, most of my family works in medicine,
so we're all very concerned about the possibility
of a Larry Elder and just for what that would
mean for masks and vaccines in the state alone.
Speaker 1: It would be a nightmare.
Now, are you are you all are you as sort of
cautiously optimistic as I am that Newsom
will prevail?
Speaker 4: Yeah, it was either early this
morning, late yesterday, I looked at the polling
data again for the first time in a bit, and
I was I breathed a sigh of relief, but I'm
I'm hesitant to be that optimistic because
I don't know what's going to happen in the
next week.
We have left of this thing.
Speaker 1: I understand.
And by the way, I'm hoping to cover the results
live on Tuesday.
Will we even get live results on Tuesday or
are they not going to be known until later
in the week?
Speaker 4: I'm I'm not sure from what I understand,
we'll know Tuesday, but I don't know if something
else is going on.
Speaker 1: OK, all right.
Yeah, I mean, I'll plan to cover some of it
anyway.
And then if we don't know exactly, we don't
know.
But that sounds good.
Yeah, great, thanks for taking my call, man.
My pleasure.
Thank you for the call.
Let's hope for the best there in in California.
It could get very ugly, very, very ugly.
And that would be.
It's I don't even want to think about it.
I don't even want to think about it.
Let's try Bart from California.
It's been a while since we've heard from Bart.
What's going on?
Bart from California, you're on the air, please,
unmuted, unmuted, you'll be able to chat with
me.
And Bart from California, last chance.
Speaker 4: I'm here, David, can you hear me
OK,
Speaker 1: now I can sort of hear you, yeah.
Speaker 4: Yeah, sorry about that.
I was trying to figure out the new I. I need
to learn more about the discourse.
OK, I really got two questions for you.
But one is, is there is there any way to get
the message, this progressive message that
you're that you're that you're also supporting
obviously to the to the other side, so to
speak?
In other words, a lot of a lot of echo chamber
going on, obviously, in the red states.
And so how can we combat that number one?
Because I think that's part of it, is there's
just no other way to get to these people.
And it seems like and would you be willing
to do something along those lines to help
get the message out?
Speaker 1: So to get to get what message out?
Speaker 4: Oh, I'll like to get your message
out to because right now it seems like a lot
of times we're basically in an echo chamber
of our own where we're listening to our more
progressive message and all that.
But I'm just trying to think of ways to help
get the message to Republicans and those people
to have basically a Fox News echo chamber.
So I'm just trying to figure out where we
can help them know maybe some of them anyway.
Speaker 1: Yeah, I mean, this is a much bigger
issue than, you know, anything I can do.
Obviously, any time I you know, when Trump
is called in, I talk to them and we have a
lot of right wingers who are who are in our
audience and know.
But but these are bigger issues about algorithms
on social media and confirmation bias.
These are really big things that are sort
of bigger than any one show.
Right.
Anything I can do, I would be glad to do.
Of course, you know, but but it just this
is just such a massive issue.
Speaker 4: I know.
Is there any possibility of of having a show
on Fox News that are so funny, but commercials
or anything like that, is there anything that
we can do is all controlled by Fox News.
They just know
Speaker 1: that everything you're saying,
could we get could we buy a commercial for
The David Pakman Show on Fox News, correct?
That is correct.
That's interesting.
That's an interesting idea.
I mean, listen, I'm more than willing to look
into that.
We'd probably have to crowdfund for I don't
know what it would cost Michael in Dellwood
now.
Right.
He's run commercials on that.
I think if we were if we put a commercial
for The David Pakman Show on Fox News, it
would be fascinating if anybody in the audience
wants to help look into that.
I would.
That would be great.
Speaker 4: Now please add my name to the people
supporting it.
However, I can help.
OK, very good.
Yeah, we'll look into that, Bart.
OK, that's one of the questions I have, is
just thinking about that particular idiom
of how to reach some of these people that
I know, a lot of them like my but even my
own siblings or are are the I mean, it's a
long story, but I have two siblings that are
problematic in this area.
Speaker 1: I gotcha.
All right.
Good.
Well, I appreciate the call, Bart.
Speaker 4: Thanks so much.
I love your
Speaker 1: show.
Thank you.
There's Bart from California advertising on
Fox News.
I mean, what could it cost?
Could it be 50 grand for a spot?
It's probably not even.
I don't know.
We should look into that.
Let's go next to Mark from Memphis.
Mark, you're on the air.
Mark from Memphis, you're on the air.
And Mark from Memphis, last chance to unmuted
and talk to me.
No, boy, I heard one, I heard David.
And it's not going well there.
That's too bad.